i always wanted to kind of like really
uh you know start a company because uh
all i always kind of admired people uh
from the technology side that okay could
we basically uh you know like really
build out engineering products which
could basically improve the agility and
i would say speed of development of the
organizations too so that it could drive
innovation at the much more faster
levels to what it is today in the
current world
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i am
joined by ayush kumar the ceo and
founder of opslift
before ops left ayush worked as a lead
devops engineer at index there he was
given the responsibility to handle the
whole cloud infrastructure which had a
budget of upwards of five million
dollars this rigorous exercise made him
realize the fundamental problems with
cloud cost optimization and how it is an
ongoing exercise
when i used to research the market of
cloud management platforms he found out
that even though there are plethora of
cloud solutions existing most of them
were just focused on providing analytics
or were just using best practices to
provide short-term solutions this made
him pivot from being a developer to an
entrepreneur and he started opslift with
the goal to help organizations manage
their cloud operations the right way
in these 20 minutes i'm excited to talk
about you and about obsolete about cloud
management and spending
where we're at today you know cloud has
taken over the world by storm uh i i
feel that you know there was a big hype
around it we sort of understood that
it's happening and now hype has been
transitioning to a bunch of other new
areas but
but we're forgetting that most of the
world is still not in cloud and we're
seeing companies transition to the cloud
especially a lot of the the large
organizations that previously were
on-prem and one of the big issues that
you're talking about here is you know
spending and management and you know we
need we need to be really smart and
intentional about how we spend on cloud
and and how do we allocate and manage
our resources it's not trivial and so
thank you very much for being here ayush
and i and i'd love to you know get
started by even understanding you know
where you know why are you in this space
so why cloud and why you
sure absolutely uh i think uh like my
journey has been pretty much i would say
very organic in terms of where i am
right now right in terms of uh uh
building ops lift and especially when
you talk about being in cloud etc so
this comes back to the fact when
uh when i completed my uh undergrad uh
in computer science in 2016 and post
that i started working for a seattle
based startup uh you know which also had
a presence in ending up like in the city
of chennai where i was hired as a first
infrastructure and devops engineer into
that company right uh and i think uh at
that point in time uh like the company
had just basically closed out its series
a or i think it was series b percent and
uh our focus was uh like clearly from an
organization's standpoint that okay hey
how do we kind of like really basically
you know um uh scale our growth like 3x
in the next 12 to 18 months of time and
that kind of like really translated to
me as a infra engineer into the company
that okay hey our cloud footprint is
also kind of like gonna
you know get matured and also grow in
size etc so uh our spends are naturally
going to get increased at that point in
time right i think we were spending
close to i think around five and a half
million dollars and we'll end kws at
that point in time and uh
that is the point in time you know when
uh our ceo like really had this
basically uh uh you know a problem
statement for me that okay hey ioship
like this is something that is sort of
like becoming a black box for me but
still is a very hefty line item in the
company's p l for me at this point in
time right uh and this seems like an
engineering problem to be solved so uh
if you could do something about it right
because this is sort of like aws which
is sort of coming under the devops
domain as well so if you could basically
solve this problem for us so it is
directly gonna like reflect uh up very
heavily on our finance side of things
all together right so this kind of like
really became a very uh uh you know
natural progression towards uh uh deep
diving into this particular problem
statement and i think uh i worked more
and more up into basically understanding
this problem
not just i would say from
aws perspective but also from a culture
perspective up in an organization right
uh so i think that's where uh uh i think
you know uh i had basically a lot of
hands-on experience on this particular
problem moving back and forth trying out
different solutions building a few
products on my own developing processes
etc etc and then i think once i was like
finally able to kind of like really do
justice to the problem statement into my
own uh i would say prior company where i
used to work on right uh that is when i
kind of like really started to kind of
have the conversations with uh other
folks in the industry across india and
the u.s said okay hey where's this
basically a problem going in terms of
other similar companies that basically
like you know uh that
uh like that were kind of that where i
was kind of literally working on and
that is where i think you know uh this
problem was kind of like really uh
evident at scale wherein every growth
stage company that i kind of like really
used to speak with everybody was kind of
like really hey dude we do experience
basically this problem like really very
frequently and not just our leadership
but also the developers in the
organization are also struggling with
this particular problem right and then i
kind of like really naturally found
myself as a fit to solve this particular
problem given that uh at some point in
time i always wanted to kind of like
really uh you know start a company
because uh all i always kind of admired
people uh from the technology side that
okay could we basically uh you know like
really build out engineering products
which could basically improve the
agility and i would say speed of
development of the organizations to
so that it could drive innovation at the
much more faster levels to what it is
today in the current world right uh so
that was kind of like my thesis uh at
the end of the day like from an
entrepreneurship perspective i saw
companies like dear dog red hat uh
you know snowflake etc being built out
of the us and i really thought that okay
hey could i build a similar company out
of india for the entire world right
so and that's where i think this problem
and the entrepreneurial kind of like
spirit kind of like really combined and
together and uh i think it was two and a
half years after after my first job i
left the job and uh started to kind of
like stall this problem for everyone uh
around me so yeah that's how kind of uh
the answer the question where is why
cloud why me and why ops lift in the
very first place kind of literally
exists so yeah that's that's the idea
so if we're looking at
the world today in terms of you know
cloud management and spending how how do
you describe the state that we're in
where are we now
sure absolutely so i think uh at this
point in time if you talk about numbers
right uh uh if you could see that aws at
this point in time is like uh really
having more than i would say billions of
dollars in basically revenue in terms of
like from a quarter to quarter basis
right
uh like so what does this translate
basically to the companies uh uh you
know uh who are i would say more than 50
in today's state are born in cloud and
let's say the legacy enterprises in
today's rate who also have accepted the
terms that we have to basically move in
the cloud
given that it is more simpler and easier
to operate at when it comes to basically
uh developing elasticity of the
infrastructure at scale right
so when it comes to basically spending
right i'm sure there is a very uh all
this data is kind of like really
available on the internet that more than
30 of the spending that uh companies are
doing in today's state right is actually
classified as a cloud waste at this
point in time right
and this this waste essentially is not
something you know that uh
people intentionally do right it's not
like that someone wants to waste money
upon the cloud right uh it's just that
how uh the timing or i would say the
state of the industry at this point in
time is looking like that everybody
wants to like really innovate like
really fast right everybody wants to
kind of like really build products like
really faster iterate upon them really
faster companies want to reach out their
product market fits as soon as possible
and once they reach out to product
market fit they want to kind of like
really scale from there and then uh if
you this is from the startup perspective
right and then if you talk about
basically the companies who are not on
cloud at this point in time right
they're primarily moving to the cloud
with the intention of that okay hey uh
it would be simpler for us to kind of
like really operate uh you know that
large heavy infrastructure which
otherwise basically is a you know set of
bare metal servers hosted in a server
farm et cetera et cetera so uh everybody
is kind of like
in one sentence moving fast upon the
cloud right that's what they essentially
want to solve their business need when
it comes to basically cloud adoption in
general right now in the process of
basically moving fast or building fast
upon the cloud right uh
what typically happens with the
companies is is that uh uh like the
architecture of basically uh the
applications that they deploy upon the
cloud starts to becoming increasingly
complex as and when they basically grow
right
and that is where i would say the
complexity of the cloud like really
comes into picture that okay hey uh if
uh our architecture is like really
literally becoming complex right then at
the same point in time our developers
need to kind of like really understand
uh that okay hey what's the pricing
model of each of the component kind of
like really working on right what
architectural efficient choices should
we make so that uh we are getting all
the performance that we need we are
innovating faster at the same point in
time we are incurring less cost as well
right and this starts to basically uh
you know uh often times in today's
startup ecosystem if i talk about often
tends to get ignored out of the speed
that people want to kind of like really
get achieved like want to solve for
right that okay hey we'll solve for cost
after some point in time we're paying
maybe like what twenty fifty like
hundred thousand dollars a month that's
okay we still have credits which we're
still basically not burning a lot of
money uh it's it's still it's still okay
right and that is where the root of the
problem kind of like really starts right
that's i would say the source
of the kind of entire problem at the end
of the day that people keep on building
basically upon the faulty architectures
etc etc and then there there comes a
particular point in time right when the
company is like i think uh at a massive
scale wherein people are spending like
more than five million dollars annually
upon the cloud it even goes to maybe 100
million dollars to what netflix actually
spends to what we see the data they
spend i think around 300 million dollars
annually upon the cloud right
so that is when basically people realize
that okay hey
all throughout our journey right we have
not so much been i would say careful
about that we have to not just basically
scale upon the cloud but scale cost
efficiently without compromising upon
the performance as well right and now it
is basically the kind of problem that is
not less than a disease in a sort of a
company right
that you have to kind of like really not
only solve for the technicality of it
that okay hey just switch off these
machines etc etc but it's more of
basically have become like a culture
problem into the company that any new
environment any new application that we
have to deploy just deploy don't worry
about the cost that's the kind of
cultural uh aspect also that kind of
feel like really really also get inside
the companies right and then of course
uh there is like bad architectural
choices there are like kind of a i would
say a certain set of i would say you
know applications that are being built
in a certain way which can't be reversed
back and that is the resultant uh at the
end of the day like people spending too
much money upon the cloud and certain
things that they can't go back to at the
end of the day as well right so that's
where people get paranoid about cloud
spend at the end of the day in today's
date right uh that it is not i would say
just a problem that okay hey you ignore
it in the first and then we solve it for
the later because it's sort of let's say
not p1 in the current day like in the
prior days right but as and when when
you scale up right this p1 problem sort
of like uh like like this problem sort
of becomes a p0 p1 inside into the
company in such a way that people are uh
you know not uh really considering this
as a technical problem but all all
together like seeing this as a you know
governance problem as a basically
engineering problem and then as a
culture problem that is very hard for
companies to basically solve at scale at
this point in time and that is where i
think you know
i would say today's state of cloud
management uh the cloud spend management
specifically you know uh a problem looks
like from an industry standpoint to what
my understanding currently says yeah
wow uh first of all fascinating um and i
and i love the way that you're
describing
sort of the situation which we've gotten
to at this point and and a little bit
about the progression of the market
there's a lot of players on that under
that are looking at the space and are
saying you know yeah this is you know
this is where we're at and this is
what's happening and and you still chose
to create a startup in this in this in
this crowded area and so if you had to
look now at sort of what what is the
holy grail of the offering of how to
support companies as they're doing this
resource management in cloud management
you know what are really the core
solutions that that people are looking
for that companies are looking for that
will actually move the needle with the p
zeros and p ones of their issues
sure absolutely first so i'll break this
i would say uh you know answer into two
parts in the way uh so i think the first
part really revolves around that okay uh
to the fact that what kind of companies
do we work with right where do we see
the problem happening the most i think
that's that's the first right and then
secondly i think uh to answering a
question that what solutions typically
these companies are like looking for
right
so in our experience with basically
speaking with the market right over the
course of i would say last one one and a
half years right
so uh
the legacy solutions that are being
built into this particular market right
uh as you mentioned i think uh there are
like a lot of players into this
particular market some have been
existent since like i would say the last
decade has sell some other new entrants
into this market like and we are also a
new entrant writer so uh the legacy
players into this market i think uh
beautifully solved the problem for the
enterprise segment of customers right uh
i mean if you take up like let's say an
oil company for that matter right or a
big i would say enterprise with more
than i would say two to three thousand
people basically working for them et
cetera et cetera right now so there the
problem is more around solving for the
process of cloud spend management right
i think uh because they like there are
like lot of people so i think it's uh
more as i mentioned i think this is more
of becoming a cultural problem than uh
like
up like in addition to a technical
problem right
as and when you basically move larger
into the kind of customers uh scale of
customers to rightly put in right it
becomes a process problem at the end of
the day so that particular process
problem is more or less i would say
solved beautifully by the legacy
companies that we see existing in
today's market as well i think that's
that's like a very much like solved
problem when it comes to i would say
large enterprise companies right but
often what kind of like if you look at
the last five years right uh especially
i think uh like to the asian market if i
like talk about right and also i'll talk
about the us market as well but i think
especially in the asian market right the
cloud adoption into the startup
ecosystem has been kind of like really
massive right
i mean to further narrow it down i think
uh if you see like companies basically
from uh
i would say series a stage two i would
say the pre-ipo stage right
every like company has been basically
adopting aws google microsoft azure
writer to the best of the capabilities
being possible at 10 today's date right
and
now like these companies are basically
you know the hyper growth company right
they want to just simply grow right like
to max to max that is what typically you
see the startup working on right that we
have to grow grow grow at any cost and
by growth at all costs which unlikely is
not the scenario in current market
standpoint right to what we all know to
what basically at this point is
happening right but i'll not go depth
into that but i think uh apart from this
right i think like growth is the more
important driver for basically these
companies right whether in terms of
number of users on their applications or
for a b2b enterprise sort of company
like more number of customers etc etc so
this is where the legacy and like
uh this is in in this sort of customer
segment right the legacy enterprise
products actually do not do a lot of
justice because here you're not solving
for the process here you are solving for
quickness of the solutions right because
here the developers basically are
working with the thesis that okay 99 of
my time is basically going into the
application development and which is
catering to a business need etc etc and
at the same point in time i'm not able
to basically dedicate that required
amount of time which is able to do
justice to uh i would say solving for
cost efficiency performance management
and security etc etc while delivering
like the next day
for the particular feature that the
company needs to generate more revenue
or they like have more users right here
the tables actually turn a lot like for
these enterprise products right because
here like people don't need okay i don't
want these these basically fascinating
dashboards which like really says that
okay your spending is like going this
way you might want to take a look into
it et cetera et cetera right uh or here
is your projections for the next three
months i mean come on like our thing is
kind of like really changing the next
day right i can't really see uh that i
can't even want to think that what's
going to happen to me in the next few
months you tell me what do i do now
right and that's where the thesis of the
problem completely changes for these
companies right and that's where we come
in right and that's where i kind of like
really decided to reinvent the i would
say wheel in terms of solving the
problem right
so now with this problem thesis right
with respect to cloud spend management
the solutions have to be designed in
such a way right that okay hey uh
like a developer who is basically
solving for cloud spend management issue
in a particular company right is pressed
with time and is pressed with context
these are two challenges basically you
know that uh a developer like really
solved so what you did we need to give
to the developer at the end of the day
right if
he happens to be the user of the product
right
that let's say uh there are like you
know um
uh like just simply let the developer
know that okay hey these are like uh
five different you know uh miss
configuration so i would say five
different bad things happening upon your
cloud at this point in time in terms of
cost and here are basically two or three
different things that you need to do
basically on a click of a button like
really you'd like to need to fix it and
if you basically click this button or
follow this process your cost would be
reduced here's a tracker for it and at
the end of the day it would get
reflected at the end of the day uh like
at the end of the month in your aws bill
and which could like really be
presented in a translated view to your
finance teams as well and in a
presentable format to your engineering
managers and to basically leadership
team as well all this being done with
minimal effort and time basically
required from the developer at the end
of the day so that you could basically
focus on uh you know building your
applications at that matter right and
spend the least amount of time in
basically solving for the cloud spend
management issues right
so that's how i would say the solution
has to be into this particular market
right so now if i break down this
solution right okay what are the core
solutions that basically people need
first is definitely people would need
not analytics insights
it's the gone case in terms of you know
when uh like you would give too much
data to basically uh you know these
developers that okay hey guys go ahead
understand these dashboards figure out
what this metrics means what this data
means what this projection means and
once you've studied this data built
enough context uh
you know go ahead and then uh you know
uh like uh develop some like apply your
brain figure out you know get an insight
out of it and then figure out an action
plan for it right
cut this entire step all together they
do not have time to kind of do this
right
simply get down to the business guys
tell me those five in plain english
simple sentences that these are five
different i would say things happening
in my ec2 in my s3
in basically this particular application
deployed on kubernetes cluster etc here
are the five things going wrong what do
i need to do fix it if there's an
automation available i would click that
automation if automation is not being
available right up
suggest me a solution over there right
uh if i need to talk to an expert i
could simply click on your platform when
your expert is available on the call
right uh simply solve the issue right
now and then we are done
right so that's basically i think one of
this like core solution that not no
analytics only action items i think
that's first solution that we kind of
like really deliver beautifully into our
product you know that's that's sort of
being used by a lot of startups across
india in the u.s right
and then uh secondly i think as and when
you like move a little more i would say
higher up into the
kind of uh like ladder right in terms of
the users right so developers this is
the core i would say problem that you
have to kind of regularly solve or give
the solution for from a managerial
perspective right to the technology
manager's perspective right for these
people i think uh
you really need to solve for that okay
hey uh cloud spend management in like uh
i would say for them has not been an
experiential journey that okay how do
they design a process uh in terms of
governance around it right given that
there is so much dynamics around it
right
so for them
it's about you know like really solving
for that okay uh
i don't want my own devops teams only to
be pressed with solving for cloud spend
management issues while they're solving
for the infrastructure i would say
growth as well right uh how can i
basically create a uh you know uh great
accountability on my development teams
uh you know uh so that they are able to
kind of like you know take care of their
cost in a more accountable way such that
they're like it's like paying like
swiping their own credit card for their
own applications right on paying for the
cloud writer so that accountability
measure right uh like giving them a
capability to basically create budgets
for different different teams tracking
those budgets up and then basically also
helping them to kind of like align uh in
such a way that okay hey uh prioritize
uh in terms of that okay hey uh if there
are let's say these four opportunities
here within these cloud budgets okay
that's fine deal with them next month
right you have to kind of give them that
capability right and if you are going
above the budget okay guys you need to
fix that first right uh and then
basically i think this uh uh i would say
uh account management capabilities to
the developers so that basically they
become responsible stewards for the
cloud spend management right that is
something that the technology leadership
of the company
is like really wanting to set up for uh
when it comes to basically you know uh
like
having a process around cloud spend
management for the developers right
that's one like from a finance
perspective that's when the under like
solution that like kind of like we offer
with respect to the finance people so
like simply understand these these are
not tech guys the finance guys are not
tech guys in the very first place right
like for them it's like okay we spent
half a million dollars this month on aws
right if they have to dig down even
further into this right no they they
can't do it because they don't
understand what ec2 is they don't
understand basically what uh
you know um
what an s3 is at the end of the day
right
what they would like actually understand
that okay okay uh if you say that i
spent like half a million dollars on the
cloud right uh and you say that okay we
are a b2b company can you simply tell me
that okay how much are we spending per
customer right and if let's say from a
customer perspective right if we are
charging our customer basically let's
say on the base of three four variables
maybe like with regards to the data size
that we kind of ingest with them with
regards to kind of let's say number of
users that we kind of have on the
platform for that one particular
customer so can you attribute basically
the cloud cost with respect to the i
would say charging drivers that we have
for the customers because that would
help me to kind of like really up you
know do that cost analysis that okay hey
the money that i'm making from the
customer versus the money that i'm
spending with respect to the cogs you
know for that customer is that kind of
like rightly being balanced or not
should i charge more to my customer
should i charge less i it could
sometimes even go benefit to the
customer but if it was not i need to
know
right so developing like solving for the
value g and entire from the developers
to like getting done the clock cost
optimization work to the i would say
engineering management level people to
basically helping them prioritize and
developing an efficient governance
process which could develop develop
accountability on developers to finance
people so that they could basically have
a translated language spoken to
basically technology people in terms of
cloud cost is the entire value chain
that you need to like really solve uh in
minutes to basically you know like uh
for a high growth startup
you know uh like for us completeness of
a spend management solution so that's i
would say that the core solutions that i
think particularly is uh required at
this point
i think it's fascinating and they i i
have about ten more questions that i
need to ask but i unfortunately i called
this show 20 minute leaders and so i
i think i think it's really it's a
really awesome take that you have on
some of the quora
i i think it was fascinating to hear and
and i think that it's a it's a great
it's an amazing um
understanding about about where we're at
and what are really the core needs that
organizations have and and and i really
love that sort of the mind shift that
you've had from from these dashboards
and the business intelligence analytics
viewpoint transitioning to the actually
actionable things that can take and then
the tracking and the way that it
integrates to the rest of the company
and organization to their kpis i think
that i think that that's really really
cool and naish thank you very much for
being here and for spending this time
with me i i really enjoyed it i wish you
best of luck with ops lift and thank you
very much for the time
sure thanks michael uh i'm really sorry
i maybe i took a little bit more time to
explain to my answers i think it's just
the way when i talk about problems and
answers i think it's just the way i get
lost into my thoughts so i see really
sorry
basically
i think it's one of the best qualities
in a in an entrepreneur just so you can
see the pat i could definitely see the
passion
coming through and how excited you are
about this problem and how and and how
how in intentional you are about the way
that you're thinking about it so that
that served quite a bit of inspiration
for me and so no need to apologize it
was it was fantastic and thank you very
very much
thank you thanks michael thanks for
having me and it was definitely
wonderful speaking with you i look
forward to speaking with you again for
sure
[Music]
you